the numbers are staggering 30% of people
want to eat less gluten 18 percent of
adults buy gluten-free foods and it's
expected to be a fifteen billion dollar
industry by 2016 but experts say only 1%
of Americans have disorders like celiac
disease specifically caused by gluten so
what gives many people think they have a
syndrome called non-celiac gluten
sensitivity and now research is telling
us that it probably doesn't exist gluten
is a protein composite you find it a lot
in wheat barley and other grains it's
the stuff that makes bread chewy and is
used a lot as a meat substitute so why
has it riled up people everywhere
our story begins in Australia back in
2011 a guy named Peter Gibson published
a crucial study finding that gluten can
cause gastrointestinal distress in
people who don't have celiac disease the
study sent the gluten-free craze into
orbit but Gibson wasn't satisfied so he
went back to the lab and followed up and
these follow studies have changed his
original conclusions here's what he did
thirty-seven self-identified gluten
sensitive patients with irritable bowel
syndrome were tested they recycled
through various diets of both gluten and
non gluten which didn't contain other
stuff that could aggravate the gut when
the study was over researchers
discovered that no matter what diet the
patients were on many of them had
intestinal problems anyways the patients
expected to feel bad on the study diets
so they did as for gluten Gibson
concluded that it wasn't a factor it
made no difference
so gluten might not be the big bad wolf
people think it is
now instead scientists think a group of
carbs called FODMAPs could be doling out
all these bad intestinal symptoms and
not the gluten
chalk another one up for science
his msg and it stands for a monosodium
glutamate
it's the sodium salt of glutamic acid
which is an amino acid